شركات ناشئه عده في انتاج ما يسمى باللحوم
المخبريه او الاصطناعيه تطمح في الحصول
على الموافقه لتسويق منتجاتها وتعاد
سنغافوره حاليا الدوله الوحيده التي يمكن
فيها بيع اللحوم المزروعه في المختبر
للمستهين بشكل قانوني
هذه الطريقه في انتاج اللحوم ستتيح البشره
استهلاك البروتين الحيواني من خلال
الاساليب تحمل اثارهم بيئيه اقل مما تسبب
به تربيه الحيوانات ولا تؤذي هذه الكائنات
تختلف هذه المنتجات عن البدائل النباتيه
للحوم كذلك المصنوعه من فول الصويا
ومكونات اخرى مشابهه للحوم من ناحيه
الملمس ونكهه لكنها لا تحتوي على بروتينات
حيوانيه فهذه اللحوم تصنع من انسجه
حيوانيه في مفاعلات الحيويه في ظل ظروف
الخاضعه للرقابه ليكون اللحم المزروع
مطابقا للمذبوح تقليديا ومع ذلك يمكن ان
تؤدي نقاط الاسعار المرتفعه وشكوك
المستهلكين الى بطاقه تحول الى اللحوم
المصنوعه في المختبر